your investors and you as a ceo
don't always have an alignment into in
regards to your goals
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on the
show my pleasure
really great to have you you know you're
the ceo of applause now and
a fantastic company that i actually
felt i've been following quite closely
ever since my time in
in the idf and building software myself
but i'd love to
to get started by by getting to know you
a little bit better how you've
come to applause to be the ceo you
actually were also the board member of
run keeper right
yeah i i was uh until it was
actually sold to a6 at the time so you
know i do like to take a few
independent board seats and have help
kind of young entrepreneurs and ceo kind
of
um you know grow their company and you
know i did it a few times one was run
keeper i think
a few years ago and one was grab card
that was another company that yeah i was
on the board
well i love you know i love ron keeper i
actually use almost on a daily basis
to run so as soon as i start i got so
excited
duran tell me what is it like to be a
board member
of a sort of b2c company
where you know there's so much
engagement with the users and and the
growth is tremendous
what is your role as a board member for
a company like
runkeeper yeah so run keeper is actually
a very good example because
you know first of all for me it was very
interesting because they had a great
founder
um i always loved working with a grant
founder i just gave you an example
you know he was the first one that came
with a mobile app that kind of tracks
your running and creates a running
community
and at the beginning he had no funding
so he was actually
uh running the boston marathon with this
like iphone
outfit so he was so passionate about it
was actually running with an iphone
outfit
uh and you can probably look it up it's
actually pretty interesting
um but i'm going to put it right over
here with my tremendous editing so right
over here there's going to be a picture
of him running with the iphone yeah yeah
i can probably send it to you we're
still good friends um
you know and for me it was a very
interesting type of endeavor because
my background is in b2b and enterprise
software and run keeper is obviously a
b2c company
um and actually one of the first ones
that focused on you know mobile
application and iphone first
and it was for me a very good endeavor
into the metrics and analytics of the
b2c company
and one of the things one of the reasons
that i joined is you know obviously
gain some more experience on the b2c
space but also kind of help primekeeper
because what happened to them is
they were the first ones that actually
came out but they were not
you know they were kind of getting their
lunch eaten a little bit by companies
like strava
that came from the cycling world and
there was a few other examples a few
companies they
you know that were acquired by under
armour etc
etc so we had to kind of mean the
investors had to kind of figure out a
way together with the ceo to put the
company on a trajectory to continue
growth and success and eventually we did
that and that was actually sold
to asics which is a you know a running
shoe company i guess uh that was a great
success for the entrepreneur and the
team and now
they're basically part of the digital um
i would say
digital agency or basic so everything
digital for asics is actually going
through the iran keeper office in bosnia
my job as an independent board member
and i think this is very important for
ceos and young entrepreneurs to
understand is that
you know your investors
and you as a ceo don't always have an
alignment into
in regards to your goals and you know
investors need to take care of their
investment
the ceo needs to take care of the
company the employee
the management team and sometimes that
creates a challenge
right many times they're aligned in
order to grow the company because if the
company is doing well everybody's
successful
but many times you know there is certain
amount of friction
and i think the role of an independent
board member is to actually kind of play
that role
where he doesn't you know his incentive
is not the investor his incentives is
not the bc his incentive is not
necessarily the ceo
there's one thing that he sees that he
really cares about
and that's a company okay um
and being a good independent board
member is like super critical for the
success of the company because you
actually bring together employees
ceos uh comp a management team
and actually the investors and actually
bring them together on the same path
sometimes it's not an easy job but you
know you got to make sure that you
always think about what's best for the
company
and that's what the good independent
board member does and
you know i i like company do you have do
you feel like you have
a stake in the company emotionally or do
you feel more of an advisor that
is you know over this operation and
obviously you have the best interest in
mind for both the ceo and the company
but
but but how how connected are you to the
mission and the values that the company
exudes
so i'm very connected and that basically
means that i would never take an
independent board seat
without investing in the company myself
oh okay
so but that's me personally not every
independent board member
you know does that so what is that why
why do you do that
i do that in order to make sure that
it's important to me
to think about the company okay
so that that's me uh by the way i
learned it from
you know an independent board members
that i had
when i was an applause his name was jeet
saxtana and he was uh he actually sold
a company uh to ibm for about three
billion dollars but you know he was my
independent
board member and you know he invested in
my company and you know i learned from
him that if you want to truly become a
good independent board member
and help the ceos and the vcs grow a
company you got to have
an incentive to make the company
successful and you know if you put your
money where your mouth is that
is always very helpful uh because you
never forget
and i always invest in those companies
and i would say i was
you know i probably were part of five uh
companies where i was an independent
board member and you know i think i had
four very good successes and you know
one failure which is
you know not a bad you know
pretty fantastic statistics
wonderful duron talk to me about
applause
writing software is difficult software
is eating the world's a quote by
mark andreessen himself what is
applause and and why is it so relevant
as the years go by because it's been
here for
some time yeah so plus has been around
for about 11 years
and the you know i would say when we
when when the company got started and
i'm also the
the co-founder of the company the idea
was really simple at the time the idea
was
we invest a lot of money in testing
software
uh people process methodology tools
but when software gets to the hands of
real people there's still multiple
issues that get
found and we always need to remember
that the reason why we develop software
is in order to serve humans right right
um
that's really why we develop software
why everybody develop software and the
idea was really simple why aren't we
successful then
the point was we're actually missing a
step and the step was actually testing
in the wild
actually simulating and mimicking your
real users your real customers
and that's a way to find issues that are
never found in a lab environment
found by automation and the idea was
simple why don't we
build a global community of test
engineers and test in the world on real
devices real configurations
uh at scale at speed in real time
24 7 365. and that's actually
what we came about indeed we actually
built a
technology platform that on one hand
side integrates with
uh product development lifecycle bug
tracking system
and cicd and on the other hand side
manages a global community of
software test engineers which is today
more than half a million
uh community members from 200 countries
uh
in regions worldwide and you know you
can think of it's a simple idea meaning
you know
you take a software product and you know
an iphone app an iot
app whatever it is and throw it over the
wall to a bunch of people
but it's not really like that because
let's talk about the complexity you know
if you take uber
as an example they actually
match a driver and a passenger for a
single point in time for a single ride
single transaction
we actually match a dedicated team with
a software product
on an ongoing basis and the team needs
to fit
the experience of the software product
and there's you know communication and
collaboration and
it's done in real time 24 7. so the
technology
and obviously incentives for the testers
in order to align incentives which with
what the company is looking for
so the complexities is actually really
high
from a technology platform perspective
and i would also say you know uh most of
our customers are big enterprise
companies so you know when you look at
your iphone or android device i'm you
know happy to say that probably 50 or 60
percent of the apps that you have out
there are probably tested by applause
and that includes companies like you
know google and microsoft and amazon but
also
you know big retailers and media
companies and
you know many types of enterprise
companies that really focus
on making their customers and users
successful
right duron this concept of testing in
the wild i think that's
so interesting because you know almost
every a
software team in the world today has
this notion of
of quality testing both software testing
right test drive test driven methodology
or qa team that runs and and
you know does a hundred manual test
cases i know in the i
in the army in in 8200 where i served we
spent you know
days test every software to make sure we
don't have any errors
what what is the difference between
testing in the wild
and the notion of you know doing tests
in-house within your company why is that
different
yeah so i think two things that
basically happen if you test
in-house you actually are testing in a
single location and you have a limited
amount of devices that you tested on
uh it's also very tiring to test right
it's very repetitive type of tasks and
you're not
actually doing you know journeys and use
cases and exploratory like
like a real user would do uh and that's
exactly what
what we do you know take the most simple
example take you know hbo
go can you test hbo go from china from
vietnam no they don't even have like
distribution rights over there
you know average regular people sitting
at home who can sign up and get and
have incentives to go and just download
the app and play with it
and they can perhaps go through a list
of tasks or they can just do a free for
all
and for every bug that they find they
get they get some incentive for it right
that's correct but it's not only like
that it's actually a dedicated team and
we actually do automatic matching
so if i'm any type of company let's say
i'm you know walmart testing my walmart
application
you want to make sure that you test it
in you know areas where
you know there is a walmart you want to
make sure that you do customer journeys
you know do a you know order from your
mobile phone and
pick it up at the store uh you want to
make sure that the whole experience
actually works well
and that's what's really being tested
and you want to make sure that you test
it on devices that are in north america
uh in central locations where they
rolled out you know
pickup in store you actually want to
really simulate and mimic the users but
you also want to have
good testers that have you know
experience and expertise
and have them dedicated to the work on
an ongoing basis and have incentive
to actually look for the things that you
care about because many times when
you know you hire a team in india they
just run through test cases
right this is a little bit more than
that because there's incentives to
actually find
faults that the customer is looking for
so he can fix it
and basically launch a better product
into the market
so but this isn't instead of of the qa
on the team
or or the or internal testing right this
is as a supplement
to really go the extra mile and say yes
we we
have caught 80 or 85 percent of the of
the bugs on our end
are testing cycles but there will
inevitably
inevitably be 10 to 15 out in the wild
because of weird devices and screen
resolutions and
and wi-fi and country vpns right
well the the honest truth is that they
actually started like that it started as
you know
augmentation to current teams but you
know as as
as we evolve that matures as a company
you know today we manage the complete
cycle for a lot of our customers on an
ongoing basis
right so i i would say that both models
are available if you want to have your
own team and kind of augmented that's
fine
if you want to have us take take
ownership of everything including
you know automation so today over time
we build you know technology that allows
you to do
automation that allows you to do
accessibility testing which is super
critical for every
mobile and web application today if you
want to make sure that you do voice
testing
you want to make sure that you do data
collection for ai and ml engine at very
high quality and then test the engine
so we actually today do all that and i
think one very important thing to note
is that many teams look at
automation and manual testing as
separate
we actually look at a very holistic way
and look at it in a very holistic way so
automation and manual testing and in the
wild in test case execution and
exploratory testing
need to work in harmony so our platform
today
is a true digital quality platform that
allows you
to actually bring all of it together uh
into a single metrics
and helps you make better decisions when
are you really ready to launch
okay wonderful okay and tell me what
what does it look like
being the ceo of a company that's 11
years old
a sas company and i mean what
how do you how do you dedicate a vision
to a company and that's 11 years old
where is it at now and and what is how
how has your role
as the ceo transitioned over the years
now that it's profitable and you're just
and you're just enjoying it
yeah so you know when the company
started remember you know we started
from an idea
like we went and raised money from a
powerpoint and that's basically it from
a concept
you know company today is completely
different right it's it's
way over 100 million dollars in revenue
it's a profitable company
we have 500 employees offices in
multiple locations worldwide so first of
all it's great to see
but you know i think it's very important
to note that vision is something that
evolves over time
right you always need to have an star uh
that you basically go and aspire to be
so if if the beginning
it was in the wild testing we want to be
this augmentation stuff and then
we want to make sure that you know we
want to be a team and we want to make
sure that all the testing is done and
now
the vision is a true digital quality
platform
the vision is evolving over time right
as the company matures and i think one
of the
most important positions and jobs that
the ceo and founder needs to do is make
sure that
everybody is aligned on a vision and
that basically means the management
teams employees the investors
they're all aligned on a vision and you
know from my personal perspective as
long as
as long as it's exciting and i keep
learning and the company is still
scaling and growing
um then i'm enjoying myself right
and you know i would say that today
applause is not the same
that it was a year ago and it's
definitely not the same that was five
years ago
and as long as that keeps on growing as
a company and doing that and
trying being the real leader in the
market and i enjoy what i'm doing
i love it is there still room for for
risk taking or
or is the more of an approach of don't
fix what ain't broken
oh you gotta take risks uh you you gotta
take
risks first of all you know i think at a
certain point in time
some companies actually do the do the
mistake
of storing stop being innovative
innovative right uh and i think once you
do that they say
you know the potential of a spiral role
uh wrote down is very very high
because you know once you're successful
yeah once you're successful you're gonna
have competitors and some of them are
you know good smart people
that they you you kind of pave the path
to them and
you know if you mess it up they're gonna
take your spot right
so you gotta continue to innovate and
you know we put
every year uh we have we have what's
called the approach labs
and that's part of our engineering team
and all they do is
you know think about new ideas and a new
concept and we're rolling out new
functionality and new features and new
capabilities and new products
you know today you can bring your own
team
as part of their close platform so let's
say you have a team of business users
that you want to test and you have the
data in one location you can do that
um there's many new functionality like
low code no code automation that we're
launching to the market which is
you know a brand new concept around
automation of uh software
so the company is investing quite a lot
in in what would be innovative
it's very important to to also make sure
that the innovation is around
your vision right um you need to
continue to strive to your vision
otherwise
you know the forces are not aligned and
it sounds like a huge responsibility
that you're taking being
sort of a you know a global leader and
what it means to have to
have quality testing and quality
assurance over products and it's almost
an innate responsibility that you're
taking on as you're
continuously thinking what is the next
step for
quality what is the next well how is the
world transitioning to testing
especially as software is developing new
languages are coming up
new technologies are arising constantly
you know you know over the past five
years
iot has completely exploded now there's
to be
you know ai models on device all around
us
and this is going to bring new
challenges i'm sure the testing new edge
cases that nobody have thought of
and and you also responsibility of
making the leap forward right
yeah and by the way those challenges
today exist
already right i mean let me give you
another and
by the way we do all that type of
testing let me give you another analogy
so
you look at voice for example and you
look at the evolution of voice
um voice is actually growing much more
than what mobile grew because of
two reasons one it's a natural way for a
human to interact with software
right uh and two it's completely device
independent
it doesn't matter if you interact with
your phone or with android or with ios
or with your tv or with your fridge
it's a natural way to interact and
that's actually growing exponentially
faster than what you know
mobile apps used to grow and that
basically means that companies are
investing in voice applications
right uh and we do a bunch of testing
around both applications and we work
with some of the
infrastructure players like amazon and
google around you know testing their
infrastructure for voice because
you know alexa is becoming more uh
sophisticated right and there's many
other companies that are investing in
voice infrastructure and ai and ml uh
infrastructure
so actually it's very exciting to be
part of that and help those companies
create a better digital experience and a
better world for all of us
very very cool they're on right before
we leave 20 minutes are always they
always end so quick but i
somehow i i feel like i'm learning so
much through this so thank you for your
time
i need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
and and again thank you for doing this
you have 500 people that you're managing
across
so many different places and it's just
inspiring to see how
how you helped grow this company from
from a powerpoint idea
10 years later to this to this global
leader on quality
and testing and as an engineer myself
obviously i know how how critical this
is and how difficult it is to really
feel confident the software that you
wrote so so
really really incredible incredible to
hear what you guys are doing
yeah so i'll give you a few words so are
persistent right so be persistent
uh believe okay you go as an
entrepreneur you go through very hard
times and you got to believe in your
vision and basically what you're doing
and lastly it's love to win right you're
doing it
you know not because of money not
because of anything you're doing it
because you love to win so
i think these are the three i would say
concept that i really love
i love it you're still investing right
in early stage companies also through j
ventures but also
through are you still sitting on board
seats right now
uh i'm actually sitting on a boat seat
of a company
which i actually can't announce because
they haven't launched yet but it's one
of my fashion so
i actually enjoy biking uh and it's a
company that is involved in in the
biking industry
so it's gonna announce later this summer
and you know once it's announced i'll
gladly here but that's that's the only
company
other than applause of course of course
of course
thank you very very much and and best of
luck with everything thank you for your
time
thank you my pleasure take care
you